c'est d'abord
permettre à un maximum de gens qui ont
envie de se retrouver de faire la fête
mais bien sûr derrière il y a une grande
opération de sensibilisation au combat
engagé contre la mucoviscidose et à la
nécessité d'investir de plus en plus
lourdement dans les travaux de recherche
qui est la première mission de
l'association vaincre la mucoviscidose
il ya des courses en ligne à des défis
en ligne on essaie de déployer un
maximum d'outils l'ain compte tenu
d'abord du contexte sanitaire et des
aléas météorologiques mais là la météo
sur saint germain est tout à fait
clément va avoir de belles éclaircies il
y aura de belles animations de belles
fêtes
les besoins sont immenses bien sûr je
vais vous donner quelques chiffres 7500
patients en france l'âge moyen de ses
7500 passion et de 21 ans et 930 d'entre
eux vivent grâce à une greffe pulmonaire
[Musique]
nous venons de connaître une une
première grande victoire
avec la mise à disposition d'un nouveau
médicament une thérapie protéines qui
s'appelle le caf trio qui permet alors
non pas à tous les patients
malheureusement 5000 d'entre eux de
pouvoir
lors
leur réenchanter l'avenir en tout cas
rendre l'avenir possible on le souhaite
c'est spectaculaire ce n'est pas un
médicament miracle c'est une révolution
thérapeutique la la réduction des
complications est vraiment
observer confirmé la restauration d'une
respiration enfin libre puisque le mucus
obstruent les branches de ces patients
est tout à fait flagrante au point que
l'on a vu au cours de l'année 2020 chuté
spectaculairement le nombre
d'indications à la greffe pulmonaire
pour mucoviscidose parce qu'un certain
nombre de patients ont pu bénéficier du
traitement à titre compassionnel avant
même sa commercialisation